investigators have busted a massive drug
ring spanning three states all this over
just the last three days law enforcement
officers in Virginia sees enough
fentanyl to kill 14 million people as
part of what they're calling Operation
cook out there are 35 suspects that have
been arrested four others still on the
run chip Reid is in Washington Forest
chip what else did investigators seize
in this bus good morning well
authorities say they seized about 66
pounds of fentanyl in addition to other
illegal drugs and money amounting to
hundreds of thousands of dollars but the
fentanyl which is a synthetic opioid had
them especially concerned this opioid
crisis is not an issue that's happening
someplace else or to someone else it's
happening right here in Norfolk
announcing the largest drug takedown in
Virginia in 15 years gee Zachary
terwilliger US Attorney for the Eastern
District of Virginia said most fentanyl
comes from Chinese labs in total
authorities seized over 30 kilograms of
fentanyl 30 kilograms of heroin five
kilograms of cocaine and over 700
thousand dollars in cash they also
seized roughly 24 firearms including an
ak-47 we're not talking about five and
six hundred dollar deals we're talking
hundreds of thousands of dollars you
know twenty thousand dollars in the
trunk of somebody's car in a gym bag you
know behind a local restaurant
Terwilliger said the bus - spanned three
states one of the 39 people charged
ordered fentanyl from Shanghai and had
it delivered to Virginia through the
mail the last thing we want is for the
US Postal Service has become the
nation's largest drug dealer tempted
police chief Terry so if you're out
there you're using firearms you're
dealing drugs and you're hurting people
in our communities this is the group of
people that's coming after you and where
were you that was meanwhile also
yesterday the Coast Guard announced the
crew of Coast Guard Cutter Robert ward
has seized about 2800 pounds of cocaine
during their first drug patrol in the
eastern Pacific Ocean the cocaine was
worth an estimated thirty eight point
five million dollars there's been an
increased effort to hold China
accountable for drugs like fentanyl that
are manufactured there and smuggled to
the US a bipartisan bill in the Senate
would sanction Chinese labs and drug
traffickers that export the drug
Gaelle all right chip thank you very
much